[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome back to yang speaks
the author of rule of the robots one of
the preeminent authorities on artificial
intelligence and its impact on us and
the economy
the author also of uh rise of the robots
which was a profoundly influential book
on me and the yang gang martin ford
welcome martin hey thanks for having me
great to be here
no problem i am pumped to have you and
this book of yours rule of the robots is
coming out this week
and i couldn't put it down because there
was so much learning and information
uh here but this is not your first rodeo
so rise of the robots came out in 2015
to great acclaim i think it was a wall
street journal book of the year uh it
was a
big
influence on me
uh and my subsequent work and for people
who are listening to this who read my
book the war on normal people you
probably recognize martin's
name
and
lessons
because i reference him very very
heavily in the war on normal people so
what was the reception to the rise of
the robots you became this very sought
after speaker from corporations and
governments am i right yeah i i traveled
to at least 30 countries i've gone to a
lot of events and still still do um
so it's it's definitely an issue that
resonates with a lot of people i think
um that book was fairly well timed maybe
you know the concern was kind of coming
to the forefront there's always been a
little bit of a divergence between i
think economists who are they tend to be
skeptical of this whole idea that
automation is going to be a real problem
you know you talk to the engineers um
even technology executives people
running companies they're pretty much on
board with this they understand that
this is an issue
and of course then you talk to average
people
and they see this happening pretty much
all around them and and they're on board
with it too so
um you know there are different
groups i think that uh sort of received
it in different ways but clearly this is
an issue that continues to
to resonate and um you know it's
unpredictable no no one predicted for
example that we'd be in the middle of
this pandemic and the impact that that
would have but uh
i think that the trajectory of this is
is pretty relentless and that you know
this is going to continue to be an issue
i'll tell you martin even throughout the
course of my campaign i think the
discourse shifted where people started
off being very very dubious
when i made a similar case
based in part upon
your
findings
about technology's impact on the labor
market but the conversation has shifted
now to what do we do about it i think
most people have stopped resisting it
and
to your point technologists will have
believed this for quite some time in
part thanks to you executives uh believe
this because they see it in their own
organizations
the people that have been on the outside
looking into this conversation are
economists who've just been plumbing the
data
and what are the primary objections that
you've heard from economists and how do
you address them well i mean the
greatest objection that you hear again
and again is that this issue has come up
many times in the past right and we've
been through technological transitions i
mean the
maybe the most
dramatic one was when agriculture
mechanized right i mean it used to be
back in
maybe the late 1800s at least half of
the people in the united states were
working on farms
and then you had tractors and combines
and all this agricultural equipment come
along and those jobs basically vaporized
right they disappeared
and economists will look at that and
they'll say look millions and millions
of jobs disappeared but people obviously
found other things to do right and and
people in fact are better off now people
are happier doing the jobs they're doing
now which require more skill and more
education and pay more than you know
being a farm hand right so it's all good
um and yes that's that's definitely
something that we could acknowledge but
i do think that the transition we're
facing this time is quite different what
we've seen historically is that
sectors of the economy have kind of
automated
you know on a sector by sector basis so
first it was agriculture
then people moved into factories right
so think of the 1950s we had an
industrial economy everyone's working in
factories
obviously now a lot of automation
uh has come to those environments the
factories have automated they've also
also offshored and so
uh now there are a lot less factory jobs
and what happened is that people moved
from factories to the service sector so
now
we're in a world where probably 80 of
the workforce at least is is engaged in
service industries
uh
and clearly what's going to happen with
artificial intelligence this time around
is that pretty much everything is going
to be impacted because ai is really a
general purpose technology right i think
i think it's going to be ultimately
almost like electricity so it's going to
invade everything doesn't matter what
sector it is
manufacturing agriculture services white
collar jobs government jobs is coming
for literally
everything so what that means is that
although well the government jobs will
be the last to go home i'm sure of that
but to some extent you know i mean
uh
you know they've gotten rid of all the
toll operators already right i mean i
mean there used to be people in boots
like money i mean i guess those people
do in fact work for the government right
so you know there are examples of that
happening um but i i agree it's
certainly not not uh the most efficient
part of
of our society so it'll take longer
but
again what i see happening this time is
it's going to impact everywhere so
unlike where agriculture mechanized and
there was this rising manufacturing
sector to to
basically absorb all these workers i
don't really see another sector now and
what can you think of that's going to
arise in the next five 10 20 years
that is going to create jobs for tens of
millions of average people
that
do fairly routine predictable things
right i mean that that
i don't think that's that's going to
exist and yet that's what we have seen
historically right you can imagine
people doing routine work in the field
in agriculture then doing routine work
in a factory and now maybe they're
working at um walmart they're scanning
barcodes or doing something relatively
routine there so the sector that people
have worked in
and you know the definition of the job
has certainly changed
but what hasn't changed is that a large
percentage of our population maybe at
least half
are doing things that are on some level
fundamentally predictable routine
they're doing the same kinds of things
again and again
and those jobs are basically going to
evaporate across the board so we need to
come up with
a way to address that we have to think
about what we're going to do in this new
world where
those kinds of jobs basically disappear
and one point i made on the trail martin
was that even if you harken back to the
industrialization of agriculture there
were massive social problems and
even violence associated with that
period we just celebrated labor day
labor day was inaugurated as a federal
holiday in 1894 because of mass riots
that killed dozens of people
and caused the equivalent of today would
be hundreds of millions of dollars worth
of property damage
um so even if people like oh we've been
through this before you're like wait a
minute the the big times you're talking
about were actually really tumultuous
and this is objectively going to be much
faster and more widespread and more
dramatic given the number of industries
impacted and the size of the economy
today
the other big objection i hear from
economists is that they think that
productivity should be increasing if we
were truly
on the cusp of automating away all these
jobs have you heard that one of
economists raised that yeah i mean
that's the number one pushback um
so the the issue with productivity what
you hear is that if in fact the robots
are coming online and doing more work
then productivity should be soaring it
should be astronomical and the reason is
that productivity is basically a ratio
right and the numerator is output the
amount of output you produce and the
denominator is the number of hours
worked throughout the economy that's
that's productivity so if
the denominator the number on the bottom
there is going toward zero as as robots
consume all the hours
then you know you're basically almost
dividing by zero right that the number
on the you know the the ratio is going
to explode right and and in fact we're
not seeing that um in fact the last you
know roughly a decade or so has been
very modest productivity and you know
there are a number of theories about
that the most common theory is that
there's a lag right that it takes time
to assimilate new technologies
that yes we're having all this new stuff
like deep learning that's finally
emerging finally being put into practice
but it's going to take time before
businesses really you know figure out
how to use those in in productive ways
and it increases productivity and in
fact that's what we saw historically
with electricity i mean when electricity
was first
introduced it didn't cause a takeoff in
the economy at two actually decades
before
um we figure out how to use electricity
in factories in an effective way so i
think that's a viable theory the other
thing that i always point out again is
that
productivity is a ratio and there's a
numerator and a denominator and
economists always focus on that
denominator they always say
the labor if the labor goes away then
productivity is going to soar but the
numerator is output right it's the
amount of stuff that we produce in the
economy and the basic reality is that
you know no one is going to continue to
produce anything whether it's widgets in
a factory or certainly whether it's a
service
unless there's someone there prepared to
purchase that right there has to be
demand and so if
uh what we're seeing is that you know
automation the impact of ai the
inequality caused by ai the fact that
that that wages are are stagnant if all
of that is depressing demand so that
there are less consumers out there that
are eager to buy
things than that of course depresses
output so so that is one i think very
important
um idea to keep in mind and it might be
a reason that that productivity is not
actually soaring so i think what
economists need to think more about
is the question is there a scenario
where yes the robots and the ai is
actually showing up and having a big
impact on the job market but it's not
necessarily being reflected
in that cartoonish obvious way that they
might expect in terms of productivity
and i think that there are definitely
arguments that you can make there
[Music]
if you're like me or if you're like most
people you probably don't eat enough
vegetables
because
it's covered you're ordering in or
you're cooking foods you like or you
forget or let's be honest like
proactively eating peas isn't and it's
not part of my mo every day so that's
why this episode of yang speaks is
brought to you by athletic greens
because this awesome powder you can
throw in some water or throw into a
smoothie and get all the vegetables and
vitamins that you're supposed to have in
your diet every single day so one tasty
scoop of athletic greens contains 75
minerals and vitamins and whole food
source ingredients including a
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more and they
all work together to fill in all the
nutritional gaps
in your diet increase your energy and
focus and aid with digestion i love this
stuff it helps a healthy immune system
and all that they need to take lots of
different multiple products and vitamins
and things like that so
if you order
right now we're gonna give our audience
a free one-year supply of vitamin d and
five free travel packs if you
get athletic greens today so simply
visit athleticgreens.com
yang enjoyed health experts athletes and
health conscious go-getters around the
world who make a daily commitment to
their health every day again simply
visit
athleticgreens.com get your free year
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs today
[Music]
oh one of the the things i i pointed out
was that if you have a society where
people have no choice but to work
um and it's inexpensive to put them to
work then you have a lot of people
working in very low productivity areas
yeah
that's right so so
yeah so i think there's a lot of that
too depressing productivity yeah
absolutely and and you know some of the
technologies we've created recently
facebook comes to mind they're probably
not productivity enhancing right they
probably
have the opposite impact they actually
you know cause people to waste more time
in the office and become less productive
so
um it's a messy noisy scenario you know
it's not something that's just clear-cut
um
but i i well you and i think
while you were doing your speaking tour
for uh rise of the robots which was at
ted very very high order stuff
uh martin and i'm not sure if i told you
at ted that i was running for president
obama
quite a bit later several months i i saw
i i found out when i saw the article in
the new york times
and i must not have mentioned it though
i had it in my head so you and i were
talking i have to say
um you and i see things very very
similarly
uh now if you talk to techno optimists
some of them
um believe that people will magically
rearrange themselves
ted you and i shared this where i was
where you always try to be even handed
in balance so you were like hey fyi i
think this is going to cause some pretty
major problems
and then some of the people there were
like ah you know it'll be okay because
they're very very optimistic um but i
came to you afterwards and i was like
yeah i think they're going to be massive
problems
yeah i mean ted is is not just
optimistic it's very let's let's be
honest it's very elitist right you know
it attracts
people who that are doing
extraordinarily well in this new economy
and maybe for some of them it's kind of
hard for them to imagine that there are
people out there that are not sharing in
that that kind of prosperity right but
the reality you know the people that go
to ted is just a tiny tiny minority of
our population right
the vast majority of people are going to
face real challenges here
and you advocated for a version of
universal basic income in your 2015 book
rise of the robots you said look this
stuff's inevitable i think you even
advocated for it in lights in the tunnel
um when did you first hear that i
actually did advocate it for in lights
of the tunnel and yet at that time i
wasn't really familiar with ubi as a
movement and and the amount of um energy
that's been put behind it so i didn't
use the words
basic income or ubi in that book i just
said people need an income stream
right we need to give them money
um so so i hadn't
quite caught up with the lingo there but
um
by rise of the robots i realized that
there was actually you know people that
had
written about this in the past and that
there was a movement and so i think that
ubi is a very important idea i think
that
you know one thing i do in this latest
book rule of the robots is i have a
section where i compare it to the other
idea i hear a lot about which is that
the government should guarantee jobs to
everyone right and and that's something
that superficially maybe sounds like a
good idea but if you really sit down and
think about it i mean it's going to be
just massively inefficient it's not
going to reach many people you're going
to have to
have this huge bureaucracy to make sure
people show up and do their government
job
you're going to attract people away from
the private sector to working government
to do what are probably going to be you
know [ __ ] jobs and then you're going
to run into
all kinds of problems if people don't
show up on time or they have other
disciplinary issues and stuff like that
so
you know you can think of various
solutions to this problem
but i think at the end of the day ubi is
the one that seems most efficient
easiest and definitely it's the one that
is going to reach the most people right
to help the most people in particular
help the people that need help the most
which
we could start with the people that are
living on the street now right that they
clearly should be pretty close to the
top of the list for
people that are going to need assistance
um
so overall i think that it's it's a very
very important idea for the future um
that we can sort of work on and refine
going forward
well you know i agree
uh and
i think that there would be real
problems with a federal jobs guarantee
that a lot of people overlook until you
dig into the nuts and bolts of it you're
like wait a minute what happens when the
person shows up and they decide they
don't like the job what if someone
decides they're not doing a good job
then like what do you do with this
person in the context of a guarantee
one joke i told on the trail was like
why not give everyone overalls while
you're at it
i mean it was a joke but that but i
think if you have a choice you'd much
rather
give people a degree of autonomy
and stimulate uh independent job growth
uh and entrepreneurship and creativity
then you would have a new massive
bureaucracy that's going to oversee
uh what's deemed appropriately yeah i
think that that's right and i think i
actually i think your
branding of it as a a freedom dividend
was really that that was good that was
good marketing um
well thank you i think he was born up
yeah but you're right i think that
one what you know there definitely are
studies that show if you give people a
basic safety net right so they don't
have to worry so much that they're going
to literally be on the street
if they lose their job or if they quit
their job
then they're going to be more willing to
take risks right and you would probably
see more people quit that dead end job
and start a small business you know and
they would know that
even if it didn't work out it wasn't
successful that
you know they'd still they'd still be
okay on some level right so you would
see a lot more
entrepreneurial activity in in the
economy so i think there are a lot of
reasons to to really recommend the basic
income
well
you've been one of the people that are
that have been getting people to open
their eyes and now in your new book rule
of the robots you talk about
artificial intelligence as the new
electricity and then you try and dig
into the reality of the fields that you
think ai is going to have
a
huge impact in relatively quickly
and then some areas that it's going to
take a bit more time
so first can you unpack for a moment
this idea of ai as the new electricity
as what you call a general right so the
idea there is that it's what you would
call a systemic technology in other
words it's not
a specialized technology that's going to
impact one part of the economy or one
part of society it's going to transform
and and basically enable everything much
in the way that
um that electricity does i mean if you
think about your daily life
virtually everything that you do
to some extent is enabled by electricity
right if you didn't have electricity
your life would be
you know unrecognizable and i think that
ultimately the same will be true of ai
it's going to be delivered to every
industry every sector of the economy
so it's going to impact us in terms of
you know commercially and economically
it's going to have an impact everywhere
but also culturally i mean you're also
seeing new forms of art being being
done with ai you're seeing um
ai chat bots that are being used for
people with mental health concerns you
know to help people
um deal with depression and things like
that
um
it's clearly gonna have an impact in
government it's gonna it's it's already
having an impact in the legal system in
some ways in ways that are concerning so
the point is that there is absolutely no
aspect of our lives it is not going to
be impacted by this and it's going to
can you continue to accelerate um so
it's like electricity in terms of its
reach and its impact but it's also very
different from electricity in the sense
that electricity is a very stable
commodity right i mean it's the same
everywhere
um has it changed much since 1950
the new electric
story with ai is completely different so
you can think of it as as a kind of
electricity that's going to be
incredibly dynamic and unpredictable and
and and really is going to drive us ever
closer to
true intelligence right to
intelligence which is something that's
kind of on the radar
in the future so it's going to be an
enormously
consequential and disruptive technology
that i think
you know when someday somebody writes
the history of all this they're going to
say that this is the point where
the nature of
our life on earth really began to change
in a very dramatic way because of the
impact of this technology
[Music]
here on yang speaks andrew and i are
very very passionate about data security
and going online without a vpn like
expressvpn is like using your smartphone
without a protective case and you all
know that guy or gal it's like you're
fine most of the time till you drop it
once in your toast and that's what it's
like not using a vpn to protect yourself
it doesn't take a lot of technical
knowledge to hack someone there's like
12 year olds that can do it with cheap
hardware hackers can make up to a
thousand dollars per person just by
selling your personal data on the dark
web so you need to protect yourself and
that's why you should use expressvpn
they've got an encrypted tunnel that
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
that hackers can't steal it's super
secure it's extremely easy to use i have
it on all of my devices phone computer
smart tv all of it it's fantastic and
frankly i was just in st lucha and i
wanted to get
nfl games and um and college football
games and i was able to do it through my
espn that i bought in the united states
because my expressvpn
helped me be in the us when it comes to
getting my data because it's super
secure it's private and you can choose
wherever in the world you want to be
using expressvpn so secure your online
data today by visiting
expressvpn.com yang that's
expressvpn expresssvpn.com
yang and you get an extra three months
free of expressvpn and i promise you it
is worth it i love expressvpn so
expressvpn.com
yang
[Music]
so you've interviewed
the foremost researchers and you've gone
to companies and industry
experts and leaders
which
parts of the economy do you think are
going to be impacted most quickly and
dramatically and then which should
people
think okay that's not going to happen
for a while and i'll share a joke that i
used to tell on the trail which was
it's not like your hairdresser is going
to be automated anytime soon you know
like that it would be so ridiculously
hard to make an edward scissorhands
robot
like a lot of highly variable manual
labor
is going to be here to stay
but there are some
fields that are going to be
transformed pretty quickly
and you've talked to folks at the
forefront what should people expect in
terms of industry change just in terms
of work the basic lens that you should
look at this through is what's the
nature of the job is it is something
that is fundamentally
routine predictable and that doesn't
necessarily mean low skilled it just
means that you're coming to work and
you're doing the same kind of thing
again and again you might be coming to
work and cranking out
a very elaborate
report you know
you might be very much a white problem
i was a corporate attorney uh for five
months martin and a lot of that stuff is
very boring and rules based there's a
running joke in law firms where the
first thing you do on a complicated
transaction
is find and replace
because you have a template of another
transaction that's kind of similar to
this transaction and so you put in the
new client's name and you just swap out
the old client's name that's like the
first move you make so so there are a
lot of highly paid white-collar jobs
like corporate law and accounting um
that involves yeah so those are going to
be heavily impacted and um
there is still i think this this kind of
preconception out there that
you know all this is something that's
primarily going to impact low-wage
workers or blue-collar workers or people
that don't have that college degree and
that that's just not true i mean there
are a whole range of white-collar jobs
that are actually easier to automate
than you know the person making
hamburgers in the fast food place
because to make the hamburgers you need
an expensive robot you got to worry
about
dexterity and and hand-eye coordination
and all and visual perception and things
like this whereas to automate the white
collar job that's just really
manipulating information so it's
actually a lot easier but in general
what i see is
there's going to be impact a big impact
in more routine work environments so i
think a lot about the inside of amazon
warehouses okay in that environment
you've got lots of robots already that
are mostly focused on
moving things around doing what robots
can do but then you've got a whole lot
of people there
um and you know lately amazon warehouse
has been a bright spot in the economy in
terms of generating jobs right but the
people in those environments are doing
the things that robots cannot yet do
which means that they're using dexterity
hand-eye coordination to pick items off
a shelf and then
you know pack up an order for a customer
because the robots are not able to do
that uh but that will change i mean um
jess jeff bezos uh spoke at a conference
a couple of years ago and he said that
within about 10 years he expected
we would have
grasping technology that was you know
roughly on a par with a human being
right and that that's going to transform
the inside of those warehouses um i
think they're ultimately going to become
a lot less labor intensive and the
reason is that they're relatively
controlled environments right you can
you know amazon has total control over
what they're doing there they can come
they can bring in new robots to do no
thing
do new things they can
separate the robots from the people they
can control all the issues there and i
think that will move forward pretty
rapidly
um
where it's going to take longer is areas
like self-driving cars right where you
know
yes the technology i absolutely believe
it's coming
but you know it's pretty clear that you
know getting 99
of the way there is is is doable but
it's that last one percent dealing with
all the edge cases the unpredictable
events the construction
the weird weather stuff uh the closed
roads
um the pedestrians you know that are
drunk or something and not paying
attention all this stuff is is really
hard to deal with
um and so i think it's going to be a
while so one one of the implications of
this i think that
is that a lot of the things that get the
most hype and the most attention may
actually underperform and to some extent
that may create a perception that
all of this is underwhelming you know
it's not moving as fast as as we thought
but at the same time the things that are
less visible less
expected inside an amazon warehouse
behind these closed doors
um what's happening with software
running on computers and automating
white collar jobs
you know that stuff is going to be
moving
forward very rapidly and i think it's
going to have a big impact so this is
definitely happening it's going to
unfold but it might not unfold in
exactly the way that a lot of people
expect you know and you've got to kind
of
separate the hype from the reality the
reality is very real it's definitely
happening but there is hype i mean and
not not to pick too much on elon musk
but he is really you know into the hype
lately i mean just the other day he he
announced a humanoid robot that tesla is
working on and he said that a year from
now we can have a prototype and this
robot said
you'll be able to say to it
go to the grocery store and get me these
items you know and robot will do that i
mean you know
i mean boston dynamics is a company
that's been working for years and years
and years on these robots and they've
finally gotten pretty good at getting
them to walk basically right or even
dance it's fine but but
the robots don't do anything else you
know they don't have any intelligence
they can't go to the store and buy stuff
and
bring it back to you right now all of
that stuff is very far in the future i
think so
you know there's there's a lot of hype
out there that kind of raises
expectations around things that we
probably are not going to see for a long
time we're not going to see
c3po from star wars you know for a long
time you know we definitely are going to
see
some very impactful
technologies and offices and warehouses
and factories and and fast food
restaurants and retail stores that are
really going to have a big impact
[Music]
i know you're all very concerned
that we had stopped doing bidet ads
not we're still doing it because yang
speaks is proudly sponsored by tushy the
modern bidet company with washes away
you know all that good good when you're
in the when you're in the john if you
will whoever's poor john got named after
the toilet whatever there's probably
some history there that's not the point
the point is that the days are awesome
they save water they save they help the
environment right you're using less
paper less litter less trash
um they're cleaner they're better
they're faster in many ways and tushy is
the modern bidet for people
um in the 21st century frankly so just
poop wash pat dry easy easy breezy um
and so it's it's simple you've got it
uses water instead of toilet paper it's
less irritating it's easy to install it
attaches your toilet in under 10 minutes
no electricity no plumbing it's awesome
eco-friendly and stylish better for the
world tushy has a full product line to
make and i quote the restroom the best
room you've got an ottoman
ottoman yeah that's how you say it which
is a toilet stool designed to help you
be at a better angle you've got the
brush that helps you keep
your bidet super clean and you've got
their awesome bidet that attach your
toilet so here's the deal start washing
with tushy bidet for a better clean go
to hellotushy.com
and get 10 off plus free shipping it's a
big deal 10 off free shipping this is a
special offer for our yang speaks
listeners at hellotushi.com
yang for 10 off after you buy install
your tushy and show it off tag them
hello tushy one word on instagram please
tag them that's hilarious uh and tag us
too because i would love to see that
hello tushy check it out get a bidet
it's awesome
[Music]
one of the things that's going to hold
back self-driving trucks uh is our
infrastructure and i was positing that
if you really wanted to give
self-driving trucks a go nationally you
would probably need to just build out a
highway expressly for self-driving
trucks which would then have very clear
sensors and markers
[Laughter]
because one of the problems is having
random cars and
trucks interacting with yours like you
said even if you're 99.9
accurate you know you can't have point
one percent crashes
let things become really problematic
uh and
i agree with you that it was fascinating
reading in your book about some of the
companies that have been working on that
problem because i interacted with some
of those companies when i was running
for president and the reason why i was
so hyped
was in large part because of the money
involved you're talking about tens
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
millions of workers
one of the areas you think that
ai is going to play a very dramatic role
very quickly is healthcare can you talk
a little bit about that
some areas of healthcare in particular
where you're dealing with information
for example you're making a diagnosis
you're doing radiology right looking at
medical images is the one area where
um
there's really an enormous amount of of
impact right now um so those kinds of
roles are definitely going to see
increased automation what you're not
going to see so much in healthcare
is the robot that replaces a nurse right
for exactly the same reasons that we've
been talking about it's just really hard
to build that so the areas where i see a
big impact are you know radiology
looking at medical images making
diagnosis
analyzing data in hospitals so that you
can reduce medical errors you know
there's all kinds of data out there
that is is well suited to analysis by
artificial intelligence and that can
have a huge impact i mean
um before covid came along i mean the
most one of the biggest
killers of people was actually mistakes
made in hospitals that were those one
you know at the top of the list of
of things that actually causes death in
the united states um
but the other area related to that
that's going to be critically important
is generally
scientific research and innovation
and that of course will include
a lot of things in the medical arena
particularly um
discovering new drugs
um new pharmaceuticals there are a lot
of companies working in that area
because it's something that's very well
suited you know to artificial
intelligence essentially a form of
search
because
uh you know molecules have a geometry to
them a physical geometry and you can by
looking at that geometry and searching
for molecules that have a particular
configuration you can actually
you know find blind drugs that will have
a particular um
function
so um
you know i think that's very exciting
the most exciting thing that's happened
in that arena
recently was was the announcement of
deep mines alphaphones alpha fold system
right that does that figures out protein
folding you know the way that
protein molecules fold into a geometric
shape is critically important because
that determines their function
uh and and this is something that
scientists have worked on for at least
50 years they've devoted entire careers
to figure out
how these molecules form into these
various shapes you know
an easy inexpensive way to do that
rather than the very expensive
laboratory techniques
and you know deep mind managed to
basically solve that problem
um and so that's i think going to be
quite revolutionary in the fields of
science medicine biochemistry
um so that's the real promise of
artificial intelligence that it's gonna
really kind of augment accelerate
amplify
our intelligence our ability to innovate
our ability to create new solutions and
to solve problems and that's something
that
we critically need because we got a
whole bunch of problems right we do have
a whole bunch of problems
one of the things that that you
mentioned in the book that i found
fascinating was that you you thought
that ai was going to
accelerate the invention of new
materials where you might have a piece
of furniture that like fits in a small
bag and then you can go spraying it
expands i was like that sounds like
magic
um so that that's a very and the fact is
a lot of people right now i think are
becoming more and more concerned about
um some of the problems attending with
ai um but imagining
fantastic new materials made me really
enthusiastic uh can you talk about some
of those types of possibilities
yeah i mean i think it's gonna
accelerate um
you know science and engineering across
the board right what you're referring to
again it
is technologies that can search for
molecules and there was a team i think
it was in the netherlands to use this
technique to find a new molecule that
had structural properties that would be
very strong very resilient but also
um could be folded up very
you know very tightly so they yeah they
were imagining you know a bicycle you
could fold up and put in your pocket or
something like that i mean obviously
that's still science fiction at this
point but that's the kind of
potential that we might see by utilizing
these technologies um and the same thing
when we apply this to climate change i
mean we need innovation across the board
right we need
not just new sources of clean energy
that's not enough we need to transform
agriculture
we need new ways to make cement that's
not carbon intensive
we need new ways to you know to to make
buildings
more um you know to conserve energy and
so forth i mean we have a whole
bunch of problems we need to solve if we
want to address climate change not just
to
mitigate warming but also to adapt to it
because we know you know some
some warming is locked in so there are a
whole
bunch of problems we need to solve and
you know it's interesting that if you
look at
the technological progress we've made
over the last half century or even the
first the last 70 years what we've seen
is this dramatic progress in computers
and in communications
but overall
things have not you know we're not
getting into the star trek stuff here i
mean we the airplanes we have are pretty
much the same as the airplanes we had
in the 1970s the cars are pretty much
the same i mean they're better they're
more fuel efficient but
you know they're not dramatically
different so we've see we've seen a lot
of kind of iterative progress
um but where you know many people like
for example the economist tyler cowan
has talked a lot about this how we've
been on this
technological
plateau a kind of stagnation across the
board with the exception of what's
happening
with computers
and uh you know my feeling is that you
know ai is maybe
the technology that's finally going to
change that you know we're going to
amplify our intelligence in a way that
allows us
to accelerate progress across the board
so
the key advantage the key
thing about ai that i believe in is that
it's not just about ai itself
it's about what it can do everywhere
else you know and this is what um
for example demis hasabus the ceo of
deepmind he says that the purpose of
deepmind is to first solve intelligence
and then use that to solve everything
else and i think that's
maybe a bit grandiose but it's really
what
we should be striving for and that's the
true potential of artificial
intelligence
yeah there's that famous uh saying we
were promised flying cars and instead we
got 140 characters
yeah right exactly that that captures
the idea that
you know in some areas we've gotten a
lot of progress and in other areas not
so much how do you think too you know
when i was a kid i watched star trek all
the time
we have the communicator from star trek
right and we've got
something along the lines of the
tricorder
but all the other stuff the spaceships
and the warp drive and all that stuff
we're nowhere close to that right so
that's what we've seen is is that the
progress has become very focused on this
one particular
area
and we really need to
jump start things across the board you
know we need much more
holistic broad-based progress
[Music]
are you staring at a screen right now
probably are your eyes getting fried
because of it
probably
so it's time for you to get some felix
gray glasses one of our sponsors on this
podcast these are the blue light glasses
that started it all five years ago they
realized the same way we know that our
eyes were not meant to look at screens
all day i'm looking at a screen right
now as i read this ad
which is not good but
with felix gray you can get lenses that
filter 15x more of the most important
blue light to protect your eyes and the
glasses look freaking awesome mine look
trendy af a little tortoise shell pretty
awesomeness i've never been a glasses
guy the only ones that like fit my face
are kind of like the ray-ban style and
these are ray-ban style but they're
clear and they look good so
you've got prescription or
non-prescription available you just need
to go to felixsgrayglasses.com
yang to check them out they're durable
lightweight and comfortable and stylish
so here's the deal non-prescription and
prescription are available again check
them out now at felixgrayglasses.com
yang that's
f-b-l-i-x-g-r-a-y glasses.com
get free shipping free returns free
exchanges physicsgradeglasses.com
[Music]
it sounds like you believe ai is poised
to get us off this plateau and get the
trajectory heading upward again which is
very exciting one of the most
popular
uh concerns out there is
the idea that ai is going to
become super intelligent and
maybe not need us so much
the the technical term is
uh agi it's a artificial general
intelligence where you'll have
uh
an ai that can think for itself and then
can improve itself and as soon as it can
improve itself it can do so
infinitely
uh i personally have been trying to tell
people look that's not the concern i'd
have i i'm more concerned that you're
going to have a dexterous robot that
replaces
hundreds of thousands of workers like
that concerns me more than having the
super intelligence
uh where where do you come out on the
concern around uh like the skynet type
scenario
right in general i tend to agree with
you i mean i don't dismiss that concern
entirely but i think it's far in the
future and i think there are a whole lot
of issues around ai that we need to be
concerned about right now so we've
talked about a lot about the potential
impact on jobs but there certainly are a
whole lot of other things there
definitely have been documented cases of
ai systems being used in in very
critical areas the criminal justice
system
screening resumes
doing loan applications where they've
been biased right against racially
biased and also
gender bias and things like this which
is is you know obviously not acceptable
that needs to be addressed now right
that's not some futuristic thing it's
happening right now uh the maybe the
scariest thing of all
is the potential for autonomous weapons
right um
this is something that the militaries
are are to some extent working on
already we could have weapons that
literally can target and kill people
without any
human being being in control of that and
there's a risk that
eventually if those kinds of weapons are
developed they might fall into the hands
of terrorists and so forth so that's a
very real issue and it's you know again
that's not
science fiction that's you know within
the next few years this is something we
need to worry about there's a treaty
around that that at least some countries
are willing to say look uh they'll
always be a human in the decision to
kill
and then there are some countries that
are like yeah i don't know
like maybe maybe we want our robots to
be able to kill
yeah so that that's um
that's an initiative in the united
nations and there are a whole bunch of
people working in ai that are very
passionate about that i mean they really
are terrified of of this scenario where
the work that they've been doing could
be used in in such a way um and as you
said there are some countries that have
signed on to a ban and some that haven't
and the unfortunate reality is the ones
the ones that have not signed on to it
happen to be the united states china and
russia so
um
you know there's not a lot of progress
happening in terms of realistically
banning this technology so i think we
need to
at a minimum make sure that
this stuff doesn't get out
um and into the hands of terrorists and
rogue actors and that kind of thing the
problem with this technology is that
there is a competitive dynamic so the
reason that the united states doesn't
want to ban it entirely or ban
development of it
is the us is afraid that china or russia
will cheat right and russia and china
feel the same way so
that that makes it very hard to put this
back in the box and that's why we're not
seeing a lot of progress on it so that's
really quite a terrifying scenario and
again this is not
the terminator scenario where these
machines wake up and and become
self-aware and attack us this is
other people utilizing this technology
to harm other people right and that's
that's the real fear here so but but to
get back to your original question i do
think we need to focus most of our
attention on these very real issues that
are looming right now
but it is true that you know building a
machine with human level intelligence
has always been the holy grail of ai i
mean it's if you talk you know i did
interview
23 of the smartest people working in
this field and they're all
tremendously interested in this they're
passionate about it it's their dream
right
to build and those interviews were in
martin's prior book uh which in some
ways is prelude to this book uh rule of
the robots um so he just
published interviews with a bunch of the
leading authorities in ai
and then some of those learnings are
here in his new book right so yeah the
title of that book was architects of
intelligence and it was basically just
interviews so the the text of the book
is is the interviews i did with those
people and then when i wrote this book
i you know drew a lot of
insight from from those people because
those are literally
i s you could call them the einstein
part of bitcoin right i mean four of the
people i talked to won the touring award
which is kind of like the nobel prize
for computer science so very very
high level people
um but anyway they are working
aggressively
on building someday an ai system that
has human level intelligence
there's a lot of disagreement over how
long it might take that to happen some
people think it's going to happen in
five or ten years
that would be quite optimistic
um a lot of people think it's going to
be 20 to 40 years and some people think
it might be hundreds of years so so we
you know it's really quite unpredictable
even the smartest people with the most
knowledge
simply you know they don't know how long
it's going to take
but it is true that once we accomplish
that
um it is possible that
a machine could become super intelligent
right i mean it could
the general theory is that a a machine
with at least human level ai would turn
its attention to
building smarter versions of itself
right it would refine its own code so to
speak
and then could therefore become smarter
and smarter maybe very rapidly that's
what's called an intelligence explosion
right and and people have two takes on
that if you're ray kurzweil
you are a techno optimist you believe in
the so-called singularity you think that
if that intelligence explosion happens
it's going to have dramatically positive
implications because everything's just
going to take off and we're going to
have all this incredible stuff and
we're going to have all these medical
breakthroughs and we're going to live
forever and all of this right
but then there are other people look at
that you know
through
you know
different tint of glasses right and see
the risk there which is that once a
machine gets that far beyond us
how do we keep control of it um
even if it doesn't become
you know malignant and actu you know
intentionally want to hurt us or
something it could in theory
get away from us and get away from our
control and so there are people
working on that right the most
well-known person is is nick bostrom
right who wrote the book super
intelligence who actually runs the
future of humanity institute at oxford
and they think about these issues and
there are a few other small think tank
like organizations
where they have very smart people
thinking about this
and i think that's a good thing that's
fine um you know because maybe 50 years
from now it really will be something to
worry about but definitely
you know i've heard some people i think
with sam harris said in his tag though
we need we need to have a manhattan
project focused on this issue i think
that's overkill right this is not
something we want to inject massive
government resources or something into
right now because it's
very unpredictable speculative and in
the future but i think it's fine that
some smart people are worried about
this scenario and and thinking about
solutions to that
again you and i see this uh similarly in
that i'm more focused on some of the
immediate problems though i do
understand the concern like you said um
and because the concern is potentially
species threatening then you know it
makes sense to
it makes sense for smart people to be
thinking about it but you know it but
there there are some other things that
happen between now and then
um so
you go around the world talking to
people about the
perils and possibilities of ai um
we've talked a bit about some of the
risks you see what are the things that
we should be most excited about it
sounds like being able to address
climate change getting off this
technology plateau
uh potentially
improving our health like here's these
are some of the things that you think
could be on the table yeah i mean i mean
all of that stuff the innovation um
you know the potential to have new drugs
the potential to be much better prepared
for the next pandemic right one of the
things you can do with artificial
intelligence is search for treatments to
an emerging virus in the future right so
so it will be an important tool for that
um
also you know we should have the we
should look at the positive side of even
if the issue that we're kind of worried
about which is what happens to jobs
remember that when we eliminate some
mundane boring job
and replace that with full automation if
we can do that then whatever is being
produced there whether it's a product or
a service gets cheaper right and more
available so
if we can adapt to the problems that we
see
in particular to the distribution of
income make sure that that people
continue to thrive then it's not a bad
thing it's a good thing okay and that
this is a solution to
to poverty right to global poverty we we
want a future of abundance we want a
future where all the things
that human beings need to thrive whether
it's material things like food
or or
things like education right that people
need to thrive those things become
cheaper more available easier to access
and they become available to people in
the poorest regions of the world right
in areas like africa where we critically
need to drive
development that's that's all great
that's a positive thing that's not
something that anyone should
feel negative about but we do know that
as that happens it's going to redefine
the the distribution of income and
there's a real possibility of rising
inequality and that's where
ideas like a ubi come in because we need
to address that we need to fix it you
know it's not that hard i mean if if
instead of the real world economy all of
this were a video game or a software
simulation which is kind of what i that
was
why the the title of my book the likes
of in the tunnel is what it is that's
kind of what i was trying to do there a
thought experiment but if you think
about it abstractly
and you said what if you have a world
where
you could still produce all the products
and services but you wouldn't need
people to do that then how could you fix
things how could you make it good and
the answer is well you just tweak a
couple things and you find some other
way to get money into the hands of
people
and let the machines do all the work and
i mean it's it's all of a sudden you've
got a utopia right you've got
some people call that
automated luxury
i mean
communism i think but but
i'm a strong believer in the market
economy okay i i you know i believe that
we in order to have progress we could we
have to leverage the incentives that are
built into the market economy and and
most important incentive there is the
incentive for
innovation the incentive to
become more efficient to the incentive
to get better at producing things and to
produce new things right all of that
is tied directly to incentives that are
provided by the market right so
even if
the one incentive that we all think a
lot about which is the incentive for
each of us to go out and work eight
hours a day even if that even if that
particular incentive becomes less
important over time the other incentives
that are part of the market of economy
especially that incentive to innovate
and to to build new companies to do new
things that's critically important and
we want to make sure that
we continue to have a thriving market
economy and i think ubi is
probably the way to do that
well it's one reason i love you martin
is that you are at heart an optimist and
a pragmatist i agree with you that if we
tweak a few things this could be a real
path to abundance and that we need to
harness ai to get us there martin ford
one of the premier visionaries of our
time his new book rule of the robots uh
it's a page turner you learn a lot it's
it's impossible not to learn a lot from
this man thank you so much martin so
great having you on
yeah great to be here thank you andrew
[Music]
you